hey guys it is Monday the 21st off
September my name is Jess and you're
watching games but news first up today
the Bioshock series may be getting an HD
re-release for current generation
consoles South African retailer has
listed the Bioshock collection for
release on November 27 on ps4 and Xbox
one now you might think this is just a
random mistake but this is the same
retailer who previously accidentally
leaked the greninja Jigglypuff and slit
unum evo 2k games has not indicated that
they have any intention to re-release
the games so we have contacted the
publisher for statements Bethesda has
published an e3 video detailing your
fallout 4 companions including more of
an insight into your pal dogmeat dog
meat is based on lead level designer
Joel purchases real-life German Shepherd
river that don't serve shown off a video
that features River in studio doing
performance and audio CAPTCHA she shown
clambering under tables trying to catch
frisbees and retrieving sticks if a
lovable canine companion isn't quite
your speed to the apocalypse you can
also get a refresher on fallout 4 other
companions who include mr. handy Piper
and Preston Garvey you can see game
director Todd Howard discussing fallout
fourth companions in our story on
gamespot new live gameplay from gorilla
Gaines's upcoming title horizon zero
dawn has been posted online The Gambler
clip from the upcoming ps4 exclusive was
recorded during a live stream at tokyo
game show while the quality isn't the
best given the circumstances we do get
to see the protagonist alloy hunting
robot dear called grazes in order to
recover resources the developer from
gorilla highlights the importance of
stealth in the game and stresses that
the game world is completely open and
fully explorable Sony originally
revealed horizon zero dawn during its e3
press conference of this year and it's
set to launch in twenty sixteen
exclusively on ps4 let me know down in
the comments if you became to play a
rerelease of the Bioshock series you can
add the game spot
for a soma review and a brand new
trailer for rise of the Tomb Raider that
is everything I have you today as always
let me know what mattered to you and I
will catch you again tomorrow